what if I told you you could combine  delicious food in a fancy time at a snow  globe in the sky inspired Rooftop in New  York City if you're deep into the  holiday spirit and you're looking for  the cutest place to Cozy up this winter  Ophelia a rooftop on the 26th floor of  the beacon Tower is a spot to add to  your list the minute you step out of the  elevator you instantly feel like you're  in a magical Winter Wonderland  but what's even better than a cozy spot  in a view of the city is the fancy  comfort bikes to match we ordered all  different things to share like their  truffle fries and of course the taste of  tower for two which had crostinis crispy  potatoes with caviar and more  [Music]  plus they have a variety of natural pot  skills and they're all garnished  beautifully and with a variety of  sitting options with faux fur and cozy  Ambiance overall it's super picturesque  and a perfect place for date night or  with friends let us know where we should  go next